im studio aus dem prozess lager stopp g7
in dem sich übrigens verschiedene
bündnisse zusammengeschlossen haben ist
jetzt lisa pöttinger zu bekommen
studentinnen und klimaaktivisten einen
schönen guten morgen danke fürs kommen
guten morgen sie sind im grunde gegen
dieses treffen der g7 warum denn
eigentlich also was ist das problem
damit dass sich sieben länder
informellen treffen und reden also das
klingt ja jetzt so ganz haben wird aber
die g7 treffen sich ja nicht einfach nur
und besprechen wie wir eine schönere
welt haben also dieses ganze märchen vom
fortschritt für die gerechtere welt das
ist einfach es ist ein märchen das ist
eine pr-strategie weil die g7 sind
diejenigen länder die historisch am
meisten für die klimazerstörung
verantwortlich sind wenn man den
kolonialismus mit rein berechnet und den
sollte man mit rein berechnen weil der
eben eine große große auswirkung auf die
ganze welt hatte die sind immer noch die
länder die am meisten mit ihren
konzernen großfürsten ausbeuten menschen
ausbeuten und was sie da machen ist
letztendlich dass sie sich treffen und
zusammen schauen wie sie günstiger
bedingungen für ihre konzerne schaffen
können das sehen wir daran dass olaf
scholz jetzt wieder noch weiter in das
fossile reingehen weil uns eigentlich
die versprechen die es schon gab
zurückziehen möchte aber das will olaf
scholz und wir haben gerade die proteste
auch gesehen paar bilder davon also es
ist ja nicht so als würde gar nicht
stattfinden aber eben viel weniger
menschen als die sicherlich auch
erwartet haben jetzt sagen sie zurück
wieder in das fossile durch den krieg
ist es fast alternativlos was sind denn
dann ihre ideen oder ihre forderungen
aktuell also wir haben keine forderungen
an die g7 fall würdige 7 nicht als
legitime gruppe sehen ich glaube was
also forderungen hinsichtlich einer
klima bänder gibt es im bereich
mobilität wenn der agrarwende
energiewende genug seit jahren also die
lösungen sind seit jahren bekannt sie
werden nicht angegriffen weil wir nicht
ein technologisches problem haben wir
nicht haben nicht ein problem dass es
keine lösung gibt sondern wir haben ein
systemisches problem im kapitalismus
wird für die profite der konzerne
entschieden weil es nicht im interesse
der mächtigen liegt eine klima wende zu
machen die ihren profiten schadet aber
sie haben es ja gerade gehört also auch
die protestler haben gerade ein bisschen
problem damit sich gegen die g7 zu
stellen gegen die demokratischen staaten
die sich überlegen müssen was können wir
tun um die ukraine zu unterstützen und
wie können wir die eigene
energieversorgung
unserer bürger und bürgerinnen zu
gewährleisten das ist eben der schritt
rückwärts der gerade gemacht wird und
olaf scholz bundeskanzler wer jetzt so
eine art klima club gründen auf
freiwilliger basis aber zum beispiel
eine co2 bepreisung da durchsetzen das
müsste doch in ihrem sinne sein jain
also ich möchte noch auf diesen
demokratie aspekt eingehen weil wie
demokratisch ist es wirklich wenn
menschen schon im vorhinein der protest
in düsseldorf gefährderansprachen
bekommen und von der polizei gesagt
bekommen sie sollen nicht zu den gipfeln
kommen zu den protesten wie demokratisch
ist es wenn menschen am samstag auf der
demonstration von der polizei verprügelt
wurden mit demokratisch ist es dass die
sich in intransparenten treffen so weit
entfernt treffen dass die aktivistinnen
dinea hinkommen wollen und eigentlich
war per gerichtsbeschluss ausgemacht in
hör- und sichtweite also nicht den
halben kilometer entfernt dass die sich
jetzt in zivilen polizei brüsten
raufgefahren also drauf gefahren werden
wie groß ist der unterschied wirklich in
sichtbaren und von uniformierten
polizeiposten hochgefahren zu werden
oder von zivis also aber noch mal die
fragen sind die co2 besteuerung ich
glaube das ist immer also innerhalb des
kapitalismus ist auch die co2
besteuerung problem weil wen trifft es
da trifft menschen wie meine mama die
ein geringes einkommen haben die auf ein
auto angewiesen sind weil sie eben nicht
in der stadt leben können wegen der
hohen miete das trifft nicht eine
susanne klatten die einfach milliarden
hat und das ist einfach total ungerecht
und deswegen müssen wir einfach die
systemischen probleme angehen und nicht
einzelne maßnahmen machen die dann
wieder die armen treffen und deswegen
richten sich ja auch viele menschen aus
der ärmeren bevölkerung geben
klimaschutz weil klimaschutz immer
bedeutet auf kosten der armen und das
ist aber kein wirklicher klimaschutz
weil was machen diejenigen die viel geld
haben die kaufen sich heraus bieten mit
ihren weiterhin werden wir nachher um 37
auch mit dem bundeskanzler drüber
sprechen und auch ihre kritik dort
anbringen ließ oettinger war das
studentin klimaaktivisten vielen
herzlichen dank für den besuch hier bei
uns